my strong support for Israel's right to
defend itself no nation should accept
rockets being fired into its borders or
terrorists tunneling into its territory
it's no moral equivalency here and that
Israel is being attacked by hundreds of
rockets their people a third of their
population has got about a 60 second
warning restraint of the Israel Israelis
in my view is is is admirable
you know the Israelis are absolutely
right in saying that they can't just sit
there and let rockets rain down they
have a missile defense system which is
working well but you know that can't be
certain and now there are drones
apparently that are being launched from
Gaza this president has not spoken up
strongly loudly clearly for our single
best ally in the Middle East who is the
only government the Middle East that
stands for for liberty and freedom and
the things that we stand for in this
country